GONNA GET A COUPLE MORE MINUTES
FOR SOME MORE MEMBERS TO COME AS
YOU NOTED IS A BUSY DAY. AND
FOLKS ARE TRYING TO GET THINGS
OUT OF THE COMMITTEES ALL GIVE
FOLKS A LITTLE BIT OF A COURTESY
OKAY. THANKS
GOING OUT.
AND WHAT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
GOOD AFTERNOON WE WANT TO BEGIN
THE ASSEMBLY.
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE.
VIA SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE WE
HAVE NOTICED THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM.
SO. LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
THIS WHERE.
AND.
UP BUT ALSO WANT TO MENTION
THAT MISTER RODRIGUEZ WILL BE
ABSENT TODAY.
.
FOR THIS HEARING.
I'M SUPPORT WOULD YOU BEGIN WITH
TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO.
SURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE SIX
OF THE ANALYSIS.
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY TO SEEK TO
SEEK TO IMPROVE THE
ADMINISTRATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFELINE PROGRAM.
.
THERE ARE PROBLEMS IN
ADMINISTRATION WE THINK THAT.
THIS BILL WILL SOLVE THEM ARE
I'LL LET MY WITNESSES CONTINUE
WITH THE TESTIMONY SO I CAN
CONTINUE TO SAVE MY FOR HIS.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD UP MY NAME IS FELIPE
IF WENT AS I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL LIFELINE
ASSOCIATION AND A JOINED.
TODAY BY MATTHEW JOHNSON FROM
CHIU CONNECT AS WELL AS MAKING
COOK WITH THE NATIONAL LIFELINE
ASSOCIATION SHE IS OUR GENERAL
COUNSEL. HERE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS BUT BILL.
ATTEMPTS TO DO A COUPLE OF
THINGS.
AS THE AUTHOR MENTION IT INTENDS
TO MODERNIZE THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM BY LOOKING AT
PORTABILITY FREEZE IN FIGURING
OUT HOW TO ADD SOME CERTAINTY.
TO THE PROGRAM SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE WITH INEFFICIENCY IN
THE WASTE THAT WE CURRENTLY SEE
IN THE PROGRAM AND.
MATTHEW CAN SPEAK AN AWFUL LOT
MORE TO THAT IN A SECOND IN
ADDITION THE BILL TRIES TO
MODERNIZE THE PROGRAM BY MAKING
IT SO THAT WE CAN HAVE MORE WEB
ENROLLMENT OPPORTUNITIES. RATHER
THAN HAVING A OF A WHAT
SIGNATURE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCEPT A ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE AS
WELL AS LOOK AT THE
RECERTIFICATION PROCESS AND
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT EXPAND THAT. IN A WAY
THAT'S MEANINGFUL THAT WILL
BENEFIT THE SUBSCRIBER AND
PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR THE
PROVIDERS AND WITH THAT BUT
MISTER JOHNSON COULD SPEAK A
LITTLE MORE TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE PORTABILITY FREEZE.
I OUTSIDE THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MATTHEW JOHNSON I'M CO CEO AND
CO OWNER OF CHIU CONNECTS LARA
LOS ANGELES BASED.
COMPANY.
IN WEAVING ONLY ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA BATES DTC. AND ALL OF
CALIFORNIA THE REST OF THE.
COMPETITORS IN THIS MARKET ALL
FROM OUT OF STATE. US WHO WE ARE
OF HEADQUARTERED LOS ANGELES WE
EMPLOY.
ABOUT SIXTY TO SEVENTY
CALIFORNIANS AND LOS ANGELES AND
THROUGHOUT OTHER PARTS IN OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE.
DELEGATIONS ARE LOOKING
EXPENDITURE RETTELLE OCCASIONS
OFFERING BOTH.
THE WHILE AND SUBSIDIZE SERVICES
WELL AS PREPAID.
SO IT'S A LITTLE BACKGROUND ON
THE COMPANY. NOW GOODNESS FIX
FACILITA PORTABILITY FREEZE.
SO OBVIOUSLY WE SPENT A GREAT
DEAL OF TIME ACTION HAVE
IDENTICAL TWIN BROTHER WHO WAS
HERE TESTIFYING BEFORE WHICH MAY
BE A LITTLE BIT.
DISCERNING AS SOME OF YOU.
THAT WHEN WE DID THIS LAST YEAR
WENT THROUGH A GREAT. DEAL OF
PROCESS AN EFFORT TO GET A BILL
PASSED TO ENFORCE SUPPORT
FREEZE.
REPORT FREEZE
IS OF AND NOT ABOUT LIMITING
ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM SUPPORT
FREEZE IT SPECIFICALLY TO.
ADDRESS THE REAL ISSUE OF WASTE
FRAUD ABUSE IN THE PROGRAM IS A
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA. IT BILLY
OF A CUSTOMER TO LEAVE YOU THE
DAY AFTER THEY SIGNED UP WITH
THEO. IS IN NO WAY A WAY TO
PROMOTE.
ACCESS TO THE PROGRAM IT REALLY
JUST WASTES MONEY BOTH FOR US IS
A CARRIER. BUT ALSO FOR THE FUN
AYE AS ITS PAYMENT TEN BY THE P.
YOU SEE SO WE ARE. HERE VERY
MUCH AND AGAIN THROUGH LIKE WE
HAVE TO RE SELL THIS ISSUE AGAIN
AFTER WE.
HAVE THE PORTABILITY FREEZE IN
PLACE
FOR ONLY ABOUT NINE MONTHS
AND NOW VERY SUDDENLY THE POOR
VOTE FREEZES OVERTURNED ABOUT
TWO OR THREE WEEKS AGO.
SO IT'S IS A MAJOR ISSUE FOR US
THE BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA. IT
DOES NOT LIMIT ACCESS TO THE
PROGRAM SERVICE TO THAT OF THOSE
NOT CHALLENGE INDIVIDUALS WHO
NEED THIS SERVICE.
ODD SO I'M HERE TO SEE SPEAKING
VERY MUCH ON BEHALF OF THIS
EFFORT IN GETTING IT REINSTATED.
OBVIOUSLY MAKES NO SENSE TO US
AS TO WHY THIS WAS OVERTURNED.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YES UP BY MAKING COOK WITH THE
NATIONAL LIFELINE ASSOCIATION
ARE ALSO KNOWN AS NALA. AND WE
SUPPORT.
THE.
THE BILL.
PRIMARILY FOR.
A NUMBER OF REASONS INCLUDING
THAT IT'LL HELP INCREASE SELF
ROBUST SERVICE OFFERINGS BECAUSE
WHEN CONSUMER STAY WITH THEIR
PROVIDERS OF THE PROVIDERS CAN
INVEST IN THE PROGRAM INVEST IN
THE DEVICES. AND REALLY.
PROVIDE GREATER.
OPTIONS FOR FOR THE CONSUMERS
AND ALSO REDUCE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS BECAUSE WHEN CONSUMERS
MOVE FROM PROVIDER PROVIDER.
EVERYTIME THEY TO THAT THE.
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR HAS
TO.
IN DEPEND TO DATABASES TO.
CONFIRM ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
SUBSCRIBER SO THAT INCREASES THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR THE
PROGRAM. AND THEN ALSO A WE
SUPPORT IT BECAUSE OF A PROPER
MOAT PROGRAM INTEGRITY AND GUARD
AGAINST.
THE WE ARE PERENNIAL WASTE
FRAUD IN THE PRE ABUSE AND THE
WAY THAT A LITTLE TOO THAT IS
BY.
AS MATTHEW HAD MENTIONED THIS
IDEA OF SERIAL FLIPPING WHERE A
CONSUMER CAN GO TO ONE CARRIER
AND THEN THE NEXT DAY OR A FEW
DAYS LATER. GO TO ANOTHER
CARRIER AND.
YET ONLY ONE CAN CLAIM THAT.
CONSUMER FOR.
FOR THE SERVICE HOWEVER VICIOUS
CREATES A LOT OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AND WITH
THE SERIAL FLIPPING IT CREATES
OF FRAUD.
BID IT ACTUALLY ENCOURAGES
FRAUD AND YOU WANT TO SAY WHY
PEOPLE FLIP.
WELL I THE THE REASON THEY DO
THAT IS BECAUSE THE A THE
OPPORTUNITY IS IS THERE JUST IF
I MIGHT I'D BE HAPPY TO SPEAK
FOR THAT YEAH YEAH. I THINK WE
HAVE IS SPEAK THAT.
AGAIN IT'S I THINK HUMAN NATURE
WHEN HE GOT OPPORTUNITY TO.
GET SOMETHING FOR FREE AND
SOMEONE SAYS YOU CAN GET THAT
SERVICE FOR FREE THE NEXT DAY
AGAIN.
THERE IS THAT OPPORTUNITY THAT
INDIVIDUAL TO GET REPEATEDLY IN
A GIVEN MONTH WEEKDAY.
REPEATEDLY AND GET THAT SERVICE
REINSTITUTED AND ACTUALLY IN
SOME CASES GET A FREE DEVICE OR
DISCOUNTED DEVICE. OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AND OVER.
THOSE DEVICES EVENT TURNED OUT
IS BECAUSE FOR SOMETIMES RESOLD.
ARE ON THEIR OWN SO THINGS LIKE
THAT'S IT SHOULD NOT BE HAPPY
WITH THIS PROGRAM IT'S IT'S
COMMON SENSE THAT. IF YOU'RE
PROVISION ITS SERVICE WHERE A
COMPANY LIKE MINE IS INVESTING
IN PROVIDING A SERVICE THIS
CUSTOMER. THAT M. LEAVE THE NEXT
DAY AYE WE INSTANTLY LOSE MONEY
ON A CUSTOMER DAY ONE WHICH
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AND IT
STARTS THE PROGRAM.
AND THEN THE FUN GETS DAMAGED
BECAUSE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL MOVE FROM
THIS FROM ONE SOURCE PROVIDED TO
THE NEXT.
AND IN TURN BY DOING SO OR BASIE
RUNNING UP THE SOME COSTS TO THE
PC FUND. BY CREATING A
REIMBURSEMENT PACKED THAT
CARRIER. SO THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING WE PROMOTE IT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE WANT TO SEE HAPPEN
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT. BE WHEN
THE POOR FREEZE WHAT'S IN EFFECT
FOR ABOUT NINE MONTHS IT WAS
VERY EFFECTIVE. OUR OVERALL
CHURN DROPS FROM SHARON MEANS
THE NUMBER BECAUSE THAT LEAVE US
ANY GIVEN MONTH.
DROPPED ABOUT THIRTY THREE
PERCENT IN A SPAN OF ABOUT.
THE SEVEN MONTHS.
AND WE'VE ALREADY SEEN IT
INCREASED BY ABOUT TWENTY
PERCENT LAST THIRTY DAYS.
JUST FROM THE OVERTURNING OF THE
SPORT FREEZE.
IT DOESN'T BENEFIT THE FUND IT
DOESN'T LIMIT THE ABILITY TO GET
THE SERVICE AND IT JUST HURTS
CARRIED LIKE US WHO ARE HERE.
AND POINT CALIFORNIANS INSTEAD
OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU I JUMP AHEAD EARLIER
SLIMMING NOW ASK FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESS IS NOT POSITION.
THE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS CHAIR
MEMBERS OF NOTS HERNANDEZ AYE
BEHALF THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK A WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSING
THIS AMENDED POSITION. ON JUST
VERY BRIEFLY ONE I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR CONDUCT ONGOING
COMMUNICATION AND WITH BOTH HIM
AND HIS STAFF. ON THIS ISSUE AND
AS OTHER BILLS AS ALWAYS WE
ALWAYS. A VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS
TURNS POSITION HAS BEEN.
.
THAT THE IMPORT FREE SHOULD BE
FOUND VERY LIMITED AND WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL WOULD
OPEN IT UP NOT JUST A CITY BUT
BEYOND SIXTY DAYS AND WHAT WE
HAVE FOUND. IN THE WORK WE'VE
DONE WITH CONSUMERS AND ALSO IN.
A THE PROCEEDINGS BUT BOTH AT
THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED IS THAT. APART
FREEZE THAT IS TOO LONG IS
ACTUALLY DETRIMENTAL TO
CONSUMERS AND EVEN THOUGH YOU
HEARD EXAMPLES.
OF FRAUD IN IN ABUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT CAN CAN
OCCUR IN THE SHOULD BE WAY
SUGGEST THAT.
HOWEVER THE OTHER EVIDENCE THAT
WAS PROVIDED TO.
BOTH FEDERALLY AND STATE LEVEL
ON ON THIS ISSUE SHOW THE
CONSUMERS BENEFIT WHEN THEY HAVE
THE THAT OPTION THE FREEDOM TO
MOVE TO VARIOUS CARRIERS THAT IS
ACTUALLY VERY IMPORTANT. FOR
CONSUMERS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THAT THE THAT THE FREEZE WAS
ELIMINATED.
ANYTHING BEYOND SIXTY DAYS WE
THINK IS VERY PROBLEMATIC I
THINK WE HAD DISCUSSIONS LAST
YEAR WENT. ON A ARE YOU BEFORE
MR QUIRK HAD A BILL ARE ON SIXTY
DAYS AND SO WE TRIED TO COME TO
AN AGREEMENT ON THAT. ABOUT THIS
THEN OPENS OPENS UP AGAIN WE
THINK JUST THAT A CONSUMER
ISSUES AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
IS BETTER. IF THERE'S NOT A
FREEZE THAT IS GOING TO BE THAT
LONG SO FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
POSING AS A MEDIC.
IT THERE'S HEAVY AT LEAST SIXTY
DAYS BUT.
I THINK THAT'S HOW WE READ IT
PROVOCATIVE THANK YOU CAN
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE BRENDA PALOMINO HERE
WITH SPRINT.
ON BEHALF OF OUR LIFELINE.
SUBSIDIARY INSURANCE WHY LET'S.
WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THIS BILL WE HAVE
CONCERNS WHICH WE'VE ARTICULATED
TO THE AUTHORED WE WORKING WITH
HIS OFFICE.
WE DO APPRECIATE AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE AMENDED SAY HE'S
GOING TO BE TAKING.
TODAY.
WE BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE
CERTAINLY A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IN TERMS OF
ALLEVIATING SOME OF THE CONCERNS
WE HAD.
THE CONCERNS HOWEVER THAT
REMAIN ARE WITH THE PROVISIONS
THAT WOULD CREATE
INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN THE
STATE AND THE FEDERAL PROGRAM.
ASSURANCE WIRELESS BELIEVES
THAT TO HAPPEN. AND EFFECTIVELY
LIFELINE PROGRAM IS ONE THAT'S
CONSISTENT.
AT BOTH LEVELS I'M FOR PURPOSES
OF EFFICIENCY I'VE FOR PURPOSES
OF OF REDUCING ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS AND ALSO FOR SIMPLIFYING A
LIFE LINE UP PARTICIPATION. WE I
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH US ON MEMBER QUIRK IN HIS
OFFICE I'M IN HOPES THAT WE CAN
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE BUT. FOR PURPOSES
OF TODAY NO OFFICIAL POSITION
BUT WE DID WANT TO REGISTER OUR
CONSULTANTS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I GET ON THE PANTS AND
REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION RURAL
TELEPHONE COMPANIES SERVING
RURAL CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
OPPOSE POSITION ON THIS BILL
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
SOME.
THAT WERE MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SPRINT WE HAVE
FOUND OUT THAT THERE IS THE
POTENTIAL.
THERE IS THE POTENTIAL OF
LOSING NOT ALL BUT SOME OF THE
FCC LIFELINE THAT WE RECEIVE. TO
HELP LIFELINE CUSTOMERS WITH
CALIFORNIA BEING OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FCC THAT IS
A CONCERN TO US.
SO WE REMAIN CONCERNED.
ALSO MANY OF OUR CUSTOMERS ARE
TRYING TO COME BACK
TO TO THEIR SERVICE THAT DOES
PROVIDE LIFELINE. THROUGH
THROUGH OUR COMPANIES AND THE
SIXTY DAY FREEZE CUSTOMERS DON'T
UNDERSTAND THEIR LIKE OKAY I
JUST WANNA GO BACK TO THE WAY
THINGS WERE AND THEY DON'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND THE PRE SO. PRO LOT
OF CUSTOMERS IT AT THE
DISADVANTAGE WE CONTINUE TO
APPRECIATE THAT THE WORK WITH
THE STAFF IN ASSEMBLYMAN QUIRKS
OFFICE AND WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
GET TO A POINT. OF OF BEING ABLE
TO REMOVE OUR CONCERNS.
ONE COMMET.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
ARE JACQUI CAN FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS AGAIN JUST.
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AND
WILL WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO.
OF REMOVE THOSE CONCERNS AS THE
DISCUSSION GOES FORWARD THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BERNIE
OROZCO WITH THE COMPANY CABLE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
NOT OPPOSE RIGHT NOW BUT WE ARE
A IN COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE.
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS HOPING TO
ADDRESS SOME CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE.
BUT TODAY JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE WE EXPRESSED OUR
CONCERNS PICKING.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THROW BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
DOCTOR QUIRK I I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PORTIONS OF
YOUR BILL THAT INSTITUTE. THE
PORTABILITY FREEZE AS WELL AS
THE ELECTRONIC SIGNATURES I
COULD TELL YOU I HAD A NUMBER OF
A CASE FILED OPEN IN MY DISTRICT
PEOPLE. THAT NOT BECAUSE OF THE
WHAT THE UP REQUIREMENT TO DO
WHAT SIGNATURE WERE HAVING
DIFFICULTY RENEWING THEIR
SERVICE AND WE HAD TO WALK THEM
THROUGH AND. OTHERS WOULD MAKE
IT MUCH EASIER FOR THEM SO BOB
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING THOSE
PROVISIONS. I DO HAVE A CONCERN
HOWEVER WITH THE PROVISION OF
THE BILL THAT ESTABLISHES A
NINETY PERCENT SUBSCRIPTION RATE
FOR THE LIFELINE SERVICE AND
LITTLE SURPRISED TO SEE THAT IN
THERE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T SEEM TO
FIT WITH THE THEME OF THE REST
OF THE BILL. AND I WAS WONDERING
BECAUSE I WOULD LOVE TO SUPPORT
I WAS WONDERING IF YOU WOULD
CONSIDER REMOVING THAT MOVING
FORWARD.
I'M I WILL CERTAINLY CONSIDER IT
I CAN'T GUARANTEE IT TODAY I
HAVE TO TO TALK WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS BUT I WOULD
CERTAINLY CONSIDER IT. WE HAVE
PEOPLE WHO.
WANTED TO BE MORE THAN NINETY
PERCENT. OF THAT THEY CHIEF
THING FOR ME IS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT. OF WHETHER OR NOT HAVING A
GOAL ABOVE FORTY PERCENT IS
ACTUALLY REALISTIC AND WHAT IT
WOULD COST.
AND.
.
PENDING THAT INVESTIGATION.
I COULD WELL REMOVE IT I JUST I
JUST NEED MORE TIME.
CHUCK I UNDERSTAND I JUST WITH
THAT PROVISION IS OBVIOUSLY
ANOTHER BILLS GREEN AUTHORED THE
SESSIONS SO. I THE REASON I
BROUGHT IT UP IS THAT I WOULD
LOVE TO SUPPORT THAT YOUR BILL
AND I KNOW. MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON MY SIDE OF THE
AISLE. WOULD ALSO LOVE TO
SUPPORT IT THAT WE CANNOT
SUPPORTED ABSENT A COMMITMENT TO
REMOVE ITSELF UP YOU KNOW TODAY
BUT I MEAN I I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
CONSIDER REMOVING IT SO I CAN
CHANGE THAT TO YES DEFINITELY
CONSIDER IT MAKE AND JUST HAVE
TO. TALK WITH EVERYONE INVOLVED.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M SCOTT WOULD LIKE CLOSE YES
UP SO TURN.
THEY'RE RIGHT IT DOES SAY AT
LEAST SIXTY DAYS I WILL
CERTAINLY LOOK AT CHANGING THAT
TO JUST SIXTY DAYS.
ARM.
LET'S SEE I.
IF YOU DON'T MIND ONE OF MY
WITNESSES MATTHEW WANTED TO TALK
TO ONE OF THE POINTS BROUGHT UP
BY THE OPPOSITION.
THAT THAT YOU TWO POINTS.
NO ONE IS OBVIOUSLY I'M THERE
FOR MOST OF OUR COMPETITORS IN
THE ROOM. AYE WELCH'S SMALL
BUSINESS.
BASIN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
NOT SEE THE LACK OF PORT FEES
FREEZES.
A MAJOR ISSUE PROCESS A COMPANY
BECAUSE IT CREATES
A UNNECESSARY LOSSES FOR
BUSINESS THAT LARGER COMPANIES
CAN EASILY SUSTAIN.
SO I FEEL LIKE SOME OF ADVICE
THERE IS AN OBVIOUS YOU. MIGHT
AFFECT US INSURANCE HA.
DON'T DON'T INTERPRET OTHER
PEOPLE'S MATLOCK HAD JUST SAY
WHAT YOU'RE CONCERNED IT MIGHT
CONCERN THERE'S ARTSY WITH THE
PORT FREEZE IS THE ABILITY TAXI
INVEST.
INTO A BETTER OFFERING SERVICE
FOR THE CUSTOMER. ON THAT ALLOWS
US SECTION TO MAKE INVESTMENT IN
CAPITAL TO ACQUIRE. A MORE VETS
HANDSETS AND WE'RE VINCE
TECHNOLOGIES ALLOW THE CUTS FROM
A BETTER EXPERIENCE WHAT SAVED
JOIN THE SERVICE WITH THOUGHTS.
I WITHOUT A PORT VISIT MAKES IN
ITS UNITS RECENTLY WERE. A LOT A
CARRIAGE ARE PULLING BACK ON
QUALITY PRODUCT OFFERING THE
CONSUMER. BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
TAKE THE RISK THE CONSUMER WILL
BE THE NEXT DAY.
THE OTHER POINT THAT HASN'T
REALLY BEEN TALK ABOUT A LOT IN
THIS.
HEARING IS.
REALLY WILL IT'S SPECIFIC TO
THE RECERTIFICATION PROCESS
SON OF OF GOING TO THAT LATER
CAN SPEAK THAT RIGHT NOW I'M
THIS IS YOUR ONLY CHANCE PILOTS
HAVE TO FIGURE AS MUCH.
SO ARE ON THE RESERVE GETS
INSIDE OBVIOUSLY RECERTIFICATION
PROCESS OF THE PROCESS BY WHICH
A WIFI CUSTOMER NEWS SERVICE
AFTER ONE YEAR. OF ABSENCE TO
CALIFORNIA THE RENEWAL RATE IS
IS NOT GOOD. AT RUNS ABOUT
THIRTY TO THIRTY FIVE PERCENT
ANNUALLY. THAT IS ARE TYPICALLY
OUR BEST CUSTOMERS THAT WE ARE
MANY KISSES LOSING. AND THE
RULES AROUND THAT ARE VERY
DIFFICULT TO MANAGE
IN SOME CASES WE CAN'T CONTACT
THE CONSUMER.
SEE DAYS BEFORE THEIR ABOUT THE
LEAVE US WHICH MAKES ABSOLUTELY
NO SENSE.
ARMS WHO WERE TRYING TO REALLY
PUSH THAT. THERE'S AN EASIER WAY
FOR THESE CONSUMERS TO ROLL
SERVICE FOR AN ADDITIONAL YEAR
AND OBVIOUSLY IN ANOTHER BILLS
BEING SUGGESTED EXTENDING
RESURFACED IN A TWO YEARS. OUT
TO MATT SIMILAR PROGRAMS EXISTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
THINK IT'S A VERY EASY EFFECTS
AND WE'VE GOTTEN.
POSITIVE FEEDBACK LOOP YOU SEE
ONE OF TALK ABOUT THAT DIRECTLY.
THAT IT'S SOMETHING IS WRITTEN
ABOUT THAT'S BECAUSE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. THE RESURFACING
LEVELS CLOSER TO A NINETEEN
NINETY TWO PERCENT.
SO CALIFORNIA BEING. THE HOME OF
TECHNOLOGY I THINK WE COULD FIX
THIS PRETTY EASILY. ARE.
AND WILL ALSO LOOK AT.
THE EXTENT TO WHICH WE CAN BE
COMPATIBLE WITH THE FEDS I. I
JUST DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS OF
THAT NOW BUT I HAVE PEOPLE
WORKING WITH ME YOU DO.
SARAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I THINK IT WAS COKE WHAT AT THIS
BILL ON HOLD ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM.
MAKING.
THANK YOU I'M.
BUT WILL NOW TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
ONE.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN.
MISS CREEL
.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT I PERCENT OF YOUR
COMMITTEE SOME EXCITED.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. A BILL THAT
WOULD HELP PROVIDE BETTER REDUCE
A COUGH SORRY.
BETTER REDUCE COSTS CELL AND
HOME PHONE SERVICES FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND TALKING AND
THINKING THEM FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF AND THE SPONSORS TO
ENHANCE THIS BILL.
LIFELINE AT THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION OR
THE CPU SEEM. FOR OUR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
HELPS OFFSET THE COST OF THEIR
HOME OR CELL PHONE BILLS.
THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR MANY YEARS AND HAS
UNDERGONE CHANGES TO KEEP UP
WITH TECHNOLOGY AND MARKETPLACE
DEVELOPMENTS.
HOWEVER THERE'S STILL LAGGING
RESIDENTIAL CONSUMER
PARTICIPATION IN THE PROGRAM
WHEN COMPARED TO THE AMOUNT OF
OUR RESIDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE.
FOR LIFELINE.
THE CPUC HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
ADDRESS THE SHORTFALL BUT THE
PROBLEM HAS PERSISTED.
TO ADDRESS THIS AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN ESTABLISHED
ESTABLISHES THE LIFELINE
OVERSIGHT BOARD OR OR THE EL EL
OB TO ADVISE THE CPUC. ON THE
EFFECTIVE DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENTATION AND
ADMINISTRATION OF THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM.
THE L. L. OB RESTRUCTURES AND
CODIFIES AN EXISTING ADVISORY
COMMITTEE FOR LIFELINE.
THIS WITH STRUCTURAL CLARIFY THE
SCOPE OF THE DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE BOARD
WHILE ENCOURAGING GREATER
CONSUMER PARTICIPATION AND INPUT
REGARDING.
HOW LIFELINE IS RUN?
BY GIVING CONSUMERS A GREATER
VOICE
THE L. L. OB WILL BE MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT IN
UPHOLDING THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF
THE BOARD TO ADVISE THE
COMMISSION. ON THE PRACTICAL
DEVELOPMENTAND OPERATION OF
THIS LOW INCOME LANDLINE AND
CELLPHONE PROGRAM.
THIS WOULD STRAIN THE ABILITY OF
THIS PROGRAM TO PROVIDE BETTER
SERVICES TO A LARGER NUMBER. OF
DESERVING LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS ON A
MONTH THIS THE ORGANIZING
DIRECTOR OF THE UTILITIES REFORM
NETWORK OR INTENT OPENS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF IT
CONCEALED SOMEWHAT THEY'LL
COUNTY. AND GILBERT MARTINEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE FISCAL INTERTRIBAL
COUNCIL.
AND I'M ASPER ADDITIONAL UP FOR
THE WITNESS SUPPORT SPEAK NO I'M
GONNA GO BACK TO. THE WAY I
USUALLY IT HERE TO MEETING I WAS
A LITTLE BIT LOOSE OUR BECAUSE
MISTER COURT AT A.
THROATY XIN COULD SPEAK SO I
LET PEOPLE JUMP AROUND I WANNA
MAKE SURE WE GO BACK TO. TO THE
STRUCTURE AND. AND.
ALCOHOL LIMIT TIME I KNOW I
GIVE A LECTURE TYPE THIS BECAUSE
MISTER CORPORATE BORN IN VANCITY
WAS NOT ABLE.
THANK YOU.
SO WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO
MINUTES. TWO MINUTES. TOTAL WILL
GET FIVE.
SITE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
THIS IS MY NAME IS ON A MOMENT
THIS AND ON THE ORGANIZING
DIRECTOR AT TURN.
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN SIX
TWO RESTRUCTURING EXISTING
COMMITTEE AND CLARIFY THE DUTIES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
BOARD.
WITH A GROWING POPULATION OF
ELIGIBLE RATE PAYERS IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY UPHOLD THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM AND ENSURE A ROBUST
PARTICIPATION ON THE BOARD. TO
CARRY OUT THE GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM WE ALSO ENVISION THAT
THE LIFELINE PROGRAM WILL BE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE BROADBAND
ACCESS AS A LOW INCOME PROGRAM.
MAKING IT MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER. ENSHRINING THIS POURED
INTO STATUE WILL HELP ENSURE A
SUCCESSFUL LIFE A SUCCESSFUL
LIFE BY PROGRAM. AS A PAST
MEMBER OF THE UNIVERSAL LIFELINE
TELEPHONE SERVICE TRUST
ADMINISTRATIVE COMMITTEE I AND
TO OTHERS OF THE THREE CBO
ORGANIZATIONS RESIGNED FROM THE
COMMITTEE. BECAUSE I FELT THAT
PUBLIC INPUT.
BY THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION WAS NOT TAKEN
SERIOUSLY OR SUPPORTED UNDER THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A LONG
OVERDUE UPDATE OF THE BODY
TASKED
WITH ADVISING THE COMMISSION ON
THE AFFECT THE DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENTATION AND
ADMINISTRATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFELINE PROGRAM.
EIGHT A AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN WOULD STRENGTHEN THE ROLE
OF THE ADVISORY BOARD. THROUGH
THAT THE RESTRUCTURING AND
CLARIFYING OF THE DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE BOARD.
THEY WOULD RECRUIT ACTIVELY
MEMBERS TO FILL VACANT SEATS
WHICH HAVE REMAINED VACANT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN TOOK
OR AS FAR AS TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE
COORDINATION OF OTHER CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAMS.
EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION ABOUT THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING US TO
SHARE OUR THOUGHTS ON THOSE.
I TWO SERVED OF THE UNIVERSA
LIFE BLANK OF TELEPHONE SERVICES
TRUST ADMINISTRATIVE BOARD. AND
JUST FELT THAT AT THE TIME THE
WAY WE STRUCTURE WERE NOT
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE ISSUES.
I ALSO HAVE SERVED FIFTEEN YEARS
JUST ROLLED OFF THE.
OF CPUC LOW INCOME OVERSIGHT
BOARD WHERE WE DO SEE HAVE
SIMILAR OF ITS POSSIBILITIES AND
WE DO SEE THE IMPACT IT HAS TO
HAVE. THE BROAD BASE OF ALL
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE IMPACTED
OR AFFECTED BY IT. AND.
THEREFORE THAT HISTORY MAKES A
DIFFERENCE I THINK I WORK WITH
AN ORGANIZATION CALLED ECLIPSE
YOU KNOW SOME UNTIL CONNIE WOULD
WORK DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
PRIMARILY LOW INCOME AND THEN
LIMITED ENGLISH SPEAKING
SENIORS.
IMMIGRANTS RECENTLY RE ENTRY AND
WE SEE THE IMPACT IT'S HAVING
WHEN SOMEBODY'S NOT THERE TO BE
THEIR VOICE
SHARE THE THOUGHTS AND
EXPERIENCES THAT THEY NEED ON
THE GROUND.
SO I THINK THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS THIS CLARIFYING IT AND
POWERING THIS BOARD. TO FOLLOW
TO BE THE CONSCIOUS TO BE THE
VOICE TO ENSURE THE COMMUNITIES.
IN THE INPUT AND CONCERNS ARE
ADDRESSED IN A TIMELY MANNER AND
I SUPPORT THAT TWENTY THREE.
FIFTH TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN.
BUT NOW I'M HERE TO READ CHARLIE
TOLEDO'S.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SISKEL
INTEREST INTERTRIBAL COUNCIL
STATEMENT.
OBSERVERS ARE FROM OUTSIDE I WAS
APPOINTED TO THE LOW INCOME
OVERSIGHT BOARD WHICH ADVISES
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ON LOW INCOME
ELECTRIC AND GAS CANISTER
CUSTOMER ISSUES. AND SERVES AS A
LIAISON FOR THE COMMISSION OF TO
LOW INCOME BRACKET REPAIRS ARE
REPRESENTATIVES.
THE ALLEY WILL BE REPLACE THE
CPC LOW INCOME ADVISORY BOARD
AND TWO THOUSAND ONE HAS WORKED
THE CPUC TO IMPROVE ENROLLMENT.
PROVIDE POLICY AND OTHER INPUT
TO THE CPC FROM PERSPECTIVE OF
THE LOW INCOME COMMUNITY AND
PROVIDE CHANNELS OF
COMMUNICATION FOR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AND I'LL I'LL BE WORK FOR THE
CPC TO EVALUATE IMPLEMENTATION
OF PROGRAMS PROVIDED TO LOW
INCOME ATROCITY. AND GAS
CUSTOMERS.
AND HOPE TO INCREASE THE PROGRAM
PENETRATION RETHINK CARRY OUT
THE GOALS OF THE PROGRAM.
THIS IS A SUCCESSFUL MODEL BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN EMULATE.
IN NOT HERNANDEZ A BEHALF ALSO
BE HAVE TURNED AND SUPPORT JUST
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I GUESS MATTHEW JOHNSON AGAIN
FROM MUCH YOU CONNECTS WE'RE
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL.
VINCENT LAY WITH THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
I'M MORE SHEILA WHICH ISN'T WHAT
AARP AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
FOR ARE THANK MISTER CHAIR YOU
KNOW. A LIFELINE SERVICE IS
FUNDED BY A SURCHARGE ON.
A TELEPHONE BILLS IN CALIFORNIA
SO I'M WONDERING GIVEN THE
CURRENT PARTICIPATION RATE IN
THE CURRENT SURCHARGE. THAT IF
YOUR BILL WERE TO BE ENACTED AND
AND IF YOU WERE TO REACH THE
GOAL OF NINETY PERCENT
PARTICIPATION. WHAT WOULD THE
SURCHARGE BE THAN TO BE ABLE TO
FUND THAT PROGRAM?
THAT'S THAT THAT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION I THINK THAT WE
PROBABLY SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS
AND THAT WE WOULD NOT WANT
SURCHARGE MYSTICAL UP.
WE WOULD LIKE HOWEVER TO ENSURE
THAT LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
SENIORS I KNOW THAT I'VE WALKED
MY NEIGHBORHOOD AND KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MANY SENIORS WHO.
LET ALONE. THAT.
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO BE ABLE TO
PAY FOR INTERNET OR PHONE
SERVICES ARE MUCH LESS CELLPHONE
SERVICES AND DON'T KNOW HOW TO
ACTUALLY USE THAT. A SMARTPHONE.
SO AND WE DON'T WANT THEM TO BE
ALONE SO WE WHAT WE WANT TO DO
IS ENSURE THAT THESE COMMUNITIES
HAVE ACCESS TO BE ABLE TO REACH
AND.
NO CALL FOR AN EMERGENCY. AND
THAT IS THE THAT IS THE INTENT
SO I WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOUR OFFICE AND SEE IF THERE'S A
WAY THAT WE CAN COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION TO THAT.
IF THAT WERE TO BE THE CASE OKAY
WELL THANK YOU ARE A WITCH SHARE
THE SAME CONCERN MEAN OBVIOUSLY
WITH ANY KIND OF STATE PROGRAM
WE HAVE TO BALANCE THE BENEFITS
THAT WERE PROVIDING AGAINST. THE
COSTS TO OUR CONSTITUENTS AND WE
SEEK A BALANCE THERE. ARE I'M
AFRAID HOWEVER THAT IF WE WERE
TO ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF NINETY
PERCENT PARTICIPATION THE
SURCHARGE ON EVERYONE'S PHONE
BILL WOULD BE SO HIGH THAT THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS WOULD
NOT AGREE. WITH THE DECISION TO
ESTABLISH THAT AS AS A WHOLE. I
WON A SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF
YOUR BILL GOES TO PAY THE BILL
OF OTHER PEOPLE THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT CERTAINLY MY CONSTITUENTS
WOULD HAVE A PROBLEM WITH AND
THAT'S WHY I HAVE TO.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
TODAY.
YES THANK YOU FOR THAT TURN IS
ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT RAISING
RATES WELL YOU USE USUALLY BE IF
THERE'S A QUESTION ASKED TO THEN
YOU RESPOND.
JUST TO KEEP ORDER.
AS ANY OF THE I WOULD BE
FASCINATED TO HEAR YOUR FOR YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THIS.
THANK YOU.
TURN IS ALWAYS CONCERNED
WHENEVER THERE IS A REQUEST FOR
A RATE INCREASE.
AND SO.
SO WE CERTAINLY ECHO ECHO YOUR
SERVICE SENTIMENT THAT WE DON'T
WANT TO SEE. OUR RATEPAYERS
BURDENED WITH WITH ADDITIONAL
INCREASES THERE IS AN EXTENSIVE
PROCESS
THAT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION GOES
THROUGH AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE DO IS WE ACTUALLY BRING
CONSUMERS TO THE TABLE TO BE
ABLE TO OFFER THEIR OPINION. ON
HOW IN IMPACT HOW INCREASE WOULD
IMPACT THEM
SO GETTING THEIR RESPONSES IS
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT. OP SO THAT
IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
WOULD SERIOUSLY BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WELL.
WELL I APPRECIATE THAT YOU KNOW
THE MISTER OF LIMON MIPS DOUBLE
CHECK IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE
WAS QUESTIONS.
ALL THIS CRAP.
UP AHEAD OF A BOOK THE THE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE IS JUST MY
BACK OF THE ENVELOPE MATH.
INDICATES THAT IF WE WERE TO
SUCCEED IN GETTING A NINETY
PERCENT.
THAT THAT WAS SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE THE SURCHARGE ON OTHER
PEOPLE'S TELEPHONE BILLS AND IT
IT'S AN INEVITABLE MATHEMATICAL
CONSEQUENCE OF. OF ACHIEVING
THAT GOAL AND I DON'T THINK THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS WOULD
BE OKAY WITH THE AMOUNT OF
SURCHARGE THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED.
TO SERVICE THAT GONE THAT'S WHY
AFTER RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR BEEN.
I NEED TO SHOW QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISCREANT WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU I.
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT.
WE ARE NOT WE'RE CURRENTLY THE
WAY THAT THE PROGRAM IS
STRUCTURED NOT MEETING.
THE GOALS THAT THE THAT IS THE
INTENT BEHIND THIS LIFELINE
PROGRAM SO MAYBE THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE IT. AND
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT CALIFORNIANS
NOT WANTING TO SUPPORT SOMETHING
THAT'S GONNA INCREASE SURCHARGE
LIKE I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND.
BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES ALSO ENSURE
THAT SENIORS. AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
THEY'RE IT THEY'RE NOT ALONE
ESPECIALLY THE SENIOR POPULATION
WHO.
OFTEN DOES NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES ARE LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK SOURCE SECURITY. TO BE
ABLE TO AFFORD WHAT.
TRADITIONALLY WOULD BE PAID AND
SO I THINK THAT CALIFORNIA
VALUES WERE ALSO SUPPORT.
ENSURING THAT SENIORS HAVE THOSE
RESOURCES WHICH IS WHERE WE WANT
TO GET. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
I KNOW TO MR LOW IS IN THE BACK
SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH
CORMACK EXISTE PUT PER SECOND.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SANTIAGO.
I HEAR.
OBERNOLTE HERE.
BONTA.
CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
LOW HERE.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
BUT VEGAS.
WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM SAW BRING
IT BACK TO AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN I MEAN TO THE FIRST BILL
TO MOVE FORWARD YOU TO FIRST AND
A SECOND.
BUT THE FIRST.
PLAYER SECOND.
OFFER MR LOW WE ARE SECOND.
SO.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ROLL.
MOTION IS DEPOSITS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO BONTA.
CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
LOW.
LOW I MAIENSCHEIN. MATHIS.
MATHIS NO O'DONNELL. PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOTEBOOKS OVER.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
THROUGH THE THREE MEASURES ON
CALL.
WILL NOT TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY SIX
AYE MR CUNNINGHAM ARE YOU READY.
WE HAVE A SECOND.
IT'S COMING AND WOOD LIKE
PRESENT PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN PERCENT LIKE TO START
BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND HIS.
.
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
DILIGENTLY ON THIS BILL AND AND
HELPING CRAFT SOMETHING THAT'S I
THINK CAN BE A POSITIVE THING.
DISTORT THE THIS BILL COMES
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF A STORY AND
I'LL TRY TO BE VERY QUICK BUT IF
YOU'LL INDULGE ME.
.
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE SENATE SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY MY HOME
COUNTIES. A DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FILED TEN CHARGES AGAINST
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS A LOCAL.
.
TNC DRIVER.
HE WAS UTILIZING AN ABUSING THE
APP.
WHAT HE WOULD DO IS ALLEGEDLY
IS?
?
ESSENTIALLY WERE VICTIMS INTO
THE. INTO HIS CAR BY SHOWING UP
IN PRESENTING HIMSELF AS IF HE
WAS.
THEY'RE.
DRIVER.
AND.
HE WAS TARGETING WOMEN THAT
WERE LEAVING. PARTIES AND SUCH
IT AT CAL POLY LOCAL UNIVERSITY.
THAT THE VICTIMS RAGED IN AGE
FROM NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWO.
HE ALLEGEDLY COMMITTED.
BURGLARY HE TAKE THEM HOME ENTER
THEIR DWELLING COMMITTED COMMIT
BURGLARY COMMIT A RAPE AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND.
CURRENT COUNTERS FOR VICTIMS.
THERE MAYBE MORE.
IN LOS ANGELES IT'S BEEN
REPORTED THAT THERE.
ARE OTHER SIMILAR CASES WHERE
PEOPLE.
ARE POSING TO BE THE PERSONS
TNC DRIVER.
AND AT.
COMMITTING HORRIBLE ATROCITIES.
I BELIEVE THAT THESE EVENTS AT
THE Q. WONDERFULLY AND
INDIVIDUALLY IT.
SHAKEN SOME TRUST AND WHAT MY
BILL SEEKS TO DO IS IS RESTORE
THAT TRUST AND. RIDE SHARING
SERVICES WHICH I I SHOULD NOTE
FOR THE RECORD I I USE THEM
MYSELF. AND I THINK THEY ARE
POSITIVE THING AND THEY'RE
HAVING POSITIVE EFFECTS JUST.
TO GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE FOR THE
POSITIVE EFFECT ON PUBLIC SAFETY
AND A LOT OF COUNTIES WERE.
TNC AT NETWORKS OPERATE. YOU'VE
SEEN DRAMATIC DECLINES IN THE
AND THE RATE OF A DO YOU LIVE
DRUNK DRIVING.
SO I THINK THERE'S TREMENDOUS
BENEFIT THESE SERVICES.
I WHAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO IS
CODIFYING STATE LAW SOMETHING
THAT YOU SEE IS REQUIRING
CURRENTLY BY REGULATION.
A BUT THAT REGULATION AS YOU ALL
KNOW COULD BE CHANGED WITH A
SIMPLE THREE VOTE.
THREE VOTES OF THE FIVE OF THE
COMMITTEE COMMISSION ANYTIME.
AND WHAT THAT REQUIREMENT IS
THAT THE RIDESHARE APPS TO
INFORM THE PASSENGERS SLASH
CUSTOMER.
THAT THE FIRST NAME OF THE
DRIVER.
A HAVE A PICTURE OF THE DRIVER.
SO THEY CAN BE. NAME
IDENTIFICATION VISUAL
IDENTIFICATION OF THE DRIVERS
APPEARANCE.
AN IMAGE OF THE MAKE AND MODEL
OF THE VEHICLE.
THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
GETTING IN. AND FINALLY THE
LICENSE PLATE NUMBER TO IDENTIFY
THE VEHICLE.
AGAIN IT'S ALREADY BEING DONE
BY REGULATION THAT SEEKS TO
CODIFY IT SO IT CAN'T BE CHANGED
IN LAW.
AND.
I I RECOGNIZE THAT.
THERE IS AND THE CHAIR I'VE HAD
NUMEROUS DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS
ISSUE AND.
OF IT IT'S A TRICKY THING A
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT NO LAW CAN
PREVENT EVERY TRAGEDY NO LAWS
GONNA.
KEEP PEOPLE FROM DOING
PREDATORY OF THINGS.
BUT I I THINK THIS IS A A MODEST
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION OF
PROVIDING.
A RESTORED TRUST IN A BASELINE.
A PUBLIC SAFETY SO THAT.
PEOPLE PARTICULARLY AND.
YEAH YOUNG COLLEGE WOMEN THAT
ARE USING THE SERVICES CAN.
PAN.
HAVE ADDITIONAL SAFETY FEATURES
THEY CAN RELY ON TO BE ABLE TO
USE THESE SERVICES IN A. IN A
POSITIVE WAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
SURE I KNOW SOME OF THE
WITNESSES MAY HAVE WANTED TO
COME UP THE AND IF YOU WANTED TO
DO THAT NOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO
SORT OF.
BUT A ADDITIONAL TIGHT
WITNESSES SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS LARA BUT
WITH TECH NET MY APOLOGIES FOR
NOT HAVING A LETTER ON FILE IN
THE ANALYSIS WE ARE PREVIOUSLY
OPPOSED TO THEM.
VERSION IMPRINTS ON INDUCTION
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHOR
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE REMOVE THE OPPOSITION
AND NOW SUPPORT BILL MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU.
SHOT OFTEN OF CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSIST
SUPPORT.
WELL AND ALSO MAP OF EVERY
TECHNOLOGIESONE I THINK THE
AUTHOR TO STAFF AND COMMITTEE WE
HAD SOME CONCERNS OF THE PRIOR
VERSION OF THE BELT BACK HER
VERSION ADOPTING GOES A LONG WAY
TO REINFORCING.
REQUIREMENTS AND HELP
PASSENGERS I DO THE RIGHT RIDE.
THERE'S ADDITIONAL SAFETY
MEASURES THAT THAT HE WAS
PUTTING INTO PLACE SUMMER
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE WITH THE
OUR AUTHOR ABOUT THOSE. SORT OF
THINGS BUT THE COMMITTEE THE
AUTHOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NAMES LARA
ASSESSED I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
LEFT WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE AUTHORS WORK HERE.
AND A CODIFYING THE REGULATIONS
IN PLACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
NO SEE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
PLEASE.
MISS COURTS OVER.
WHAT I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AGAIN AS?
A LITTLE BIT OF THE OLDER
GENERATION IF YOU WANT TO CALL
ME UP MY OF ADULT CHILDREN HAVE
USED SOME OF THE RIDE SHARE
PROGRAMS MUCH MORE THAN MYSELF.
I AND I KNOW THAT I ALWAYS HAVE
THE CONCERN OF MY DAUGHTERS.
TAKING. US SOME TYPE OF
TRANSPORTATION ANY
TRANSPORTATION AND SOME OF THESE
VERIFICATIONS I THINK I WOULD
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
I ALSO KNOW THAT AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION FOR THE WRITERS
THEMSELVES LIKE YOU SAY MAKING
SURE I BECAUSE I'VE WATCHED THIS
THERE WAS A PROGRAM. WAS ON ONE
OF THE.
MORNING NEWS CHANNELS ABOUT A
SOME OF THE.
CONCERNS THAT HAVE HAPPENED IN
SOME OF THESE RIDER SHIPS AND
THEY TALKED ABOUT. YOU KNOW
MAKING SURE YOU NOTICE WHO THE
DRIVER IS IS THAT YOU ACTUALLY
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE JUST GET IN
THE CAR THEY'RE NOT EVEN REALLY
LOOKING OUT THE DRIVER SO SENSE
THAT.
SHOW AIRED I'VE WATCHED DRIVERS
AND I'VE SEEN THAT THEY JUST HOP
INTO A CAR THEY'RE NOT EVEN
REALLY CHECKING IDENTIFICATION
THEY MIGHT HAVE THE LICENSE BUT
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING AT THE
PERSON.
I SAW I THINK THIS A WOOD UGH GO
A LONG WAY IN SAFETY BUT ALSO AS
A MOM MAKE ME FEEL A LITTLE BIT
MORE CONFIDENT IN MY DAUGHTER'S
WRITING ALONE.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MY THANK YOU FOR WORK IN THE
COMMITTEE HAD AND REALLY MAKING
THIS A.
SOMETHING THAT'LL IMPACT YOUR
DISTRICT
AND I HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
STATE CALIFORNIA'S WELL.
HAVING SAID THAT WOULD LIKE
CLOSE. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FERNANDO.
WE WOULD NEED A FIRST OR SECOND.
BUT WE HAVE A PERSON A SECOND I
APOLOGIZE.
MEMSIC TERRY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
PORTION IS DEPOSIT TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SANTIAGO ON.
SANTIAGO AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING BONTA.
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE HOLDEN.
LOW.
LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
BONTA.
BONTA NOT VOTING.
SEVEN ZERO MEASURES OUT.
NOW WILL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER FOR
A. B. THIRTY ONE ELEVEN UM'S
GARCIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES.
INTRODUCED AB THREE ELEVEN.
THREE ONE ONE ONE.
A WIRELESS LIKE MINE SERVICE IS
A VITAL.
SERVICE FOR LOW INCOME AND
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
ONLY THIRTY FOUR PERCENT OF
THOSE ELIGIBLE.
S. WIRELESS SERVICE ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM.
UNDER EXISTING LAW.
IT'S CRITICAL SERVICES LIMITED
TO ONE SUBSCRIBER PER PLACE OF
RESIDENCE.
THE REENTRY POPULATION
OFTENTIMES PARTICIPATES IN
SHARED HOUSING AS THEY
TRANSITION FROM PRESENT TO
CAREER MAKING THE SERVICE
UNAVAILABLE TO THEM.
ADDITIONALLY THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED POPULATION OFTEN
DOES NOT HAVE A VALID ID. TO
QUALIFY FOR MY PLANE SERVICES
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY WERE
PREVIOUSLY WARDS OF THE STATE.
AB THREE ONE ONE ONE ADDRESSES
THE LIFELINE PROGRAM
DEFICIENCIES RESULTING IN LOW
PARTICIPATION BY ALLOWING
MULTIPLE LIKE MINE. TELEPHONE
SERVICES GRABBERS TO MAINTAIN
SAFE.
THE SAME PRINCIPLE PLACE
A RESIDENCY.
RESPECT AS FOR I WILL.
BUT WHEN THIS IS A PART.
YES WE SUPPORT THIS BILL AS
WELL.
AND MR GARCIA.
DIE HERE THAT YOU ACCEPT THE
AMENDED YES WE ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND WE HAVE
A A FIRST.
AND WE WOULD NEED A SECOND.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THAT LED WITH THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MR O..
EXPOSURE CHAIR SO I LIFTING THE
ONE.
SERVICE PER HOUSEHOLD RULE BUT
OBVIOUSLY BE A SUBSTANTIAL
EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM.
BUT HOW MANY ADDITIONAL
HOUSEHOLDS AS A PERCENTAGE OF
THOSE CURRENTLY ENROLLED YOU
THINK THIS WOULD ADD. AND WHAT
IMPACT DO YOU THINK THAT THAT
WOULD HAVE ON.
THE TELEPHONE BILLS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE NOT RULED.
LOOK IT'S MINOR SENATE CAN SPEAK
WITHOUT US IN OUR EFFORTS TO TRY
TO SERVICE POPULATION.
GIVEN THAT THE LARGE PART OF
PUBLIC TO QUALIFY THE SOURCES
FROM THE UNDERSERVED AT CURRENT
LEVELS.
OUR VIEWS THIS POPULATION IS
NOT THAT LARGE IT WOULD
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE.
THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF CONSUMERS
GETTING SERVICE THROUGH WHAT
FUND PROGRAM.
SO IT'S A.
ONE WAY OF SAN FROM UP IMPACT ON
THE BUDGET OR INCREASING TAXES A
LOT THAT WOULD AFFECT AT ALL.
OKAY DOT I KNOW I I HAVE TO
DISAGREE WITH THAT BECAUSE THE
P. YOU SEE. REGULAR SETS THE
SURCHARGE ON TELEPHONE BILLS. TO
BE ABLE TO FUND THE PROGRAM
BASED ON THE CURRENT DEMAND SO I
THINK BY DEFINITION IF WE EXPAND
THE NUMBER OF HOUSEHOLDS ARE
ELIGIBLE. THAT EXPANDS THE
PROGRAM IN THE FEW SEE WOULD
HAVE TO RAISE A SURCHARGE SO
WELL I DON'T.
COULD SPEAK UP THAT'S WHEN
ANOTHER THROUGH THE CHAIR OKAY
I'M SORRY I DON'T START A BACK
AND FORTH AND IT.
IF YOU'D ASKED THE QUESTION YOU
MAY RESPOND.
.
AND I GUESS HE'S ASKING.
THAT YOU YOU BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S A SKIRT SURCHARGE ON
THAT WOULD INCREASE.
AND YOU WANTED THE ANSWER TO HOW
YOU RECONCILE THAT WITH THE
ANSWER OF NOT HAVING SURCHARGE
INCREASE LET ME RESTATE SO I
BELIEVE THAT. IF THE NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS IN THE PROGRAM.
RISES AS A RESULT OF THIS
LEGISLATION THE P. YOU SEEN
WOULD HAVE NO CHOICE EXCEPT TO
RAISE THE SURCHARGE BE ABLE TO
FUND THE PROGRAM DO YOU AGREE
WITH THAT.
ACTION AT THIS YEAR AT THAT
BECAUSE THESE SURCHARGE IS
ALREADY INCREASED SEVERAL TIMES
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
AND THERE IS AT LEAST FROM OUR
MEASURES FOR AN ADEQUATE BUDGET
THE FUND.
IT SUCKS MATCH THE PROGRAM NOT
ONLY FOR. INCREASE ENROLLMENT
BUT ALSO FOR INDIVIDUALS LIKE
THAT'S WERE NOT SERVE NOW.
OKAY WELL WHAT DEGREE TO
DISAGREEMENT LAST YEAR THE P.
YOU SEE DECREASED THE SURCHARGE
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF DEMAND SO
MUCH THAT'S ONE OF MY BIG
CONCERNS.
ASSEMBLYMAN WITH THIS BILL IS
THAT.
I THINK THAT IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE THE SURCHARGE ON
CALIFORNIA'S TELEPHONES BILLS
BUT NOT A KIND OF A BIGGER.
PHILOSOPHICAL ISSUE WITH THE
BILL WHICH IS THAT. THE.
MORE UNIVERSAL TELEPHONE
SERVICES ACT THAT ESTABLISHED
LIFELINE PROGRAM BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN THE EXPRESS PURPOSE
OF THAT WAS NOT TO GIVE
CALIFORNIANS SOMETHING THAT WE
THOUGHT THEY SHOULD HAVE. IT WAS
TO GIVE SOMETHING CALIFORNIANS
THAT SOMETHING THAT WAS VITAL
FOR THEM TO HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST. CONCERNS WAS THE
ABILITY TO CALL NINE ONE ONE
SOMEONE'S BREAKING YOUR HOUSE OR
IF YOU HAVE A MEDICAL EMERGENCY
BUT THAT WAS REALLY THE DRIVER
WHEN THE LIFELINE PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED. AND THAT'S WHY THE
ONE SUBSCRIBER PER HOUSEHOLD
RULE WAS SET INTO PLACE SO I
HAVE A BIG PROBLEM WITH CHANGING
THE PHILOSOPHY OF THE PROGRAM.
NO FROM SOMETHING THAT'S VITAL
TO SOMETHING THAT WE JUST THINK
PEOPLE OUGHT TO HAVE AND THAT'S
WHY AFTER RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
IT.
I MEAN WANT TO CLEAR THAT UP IN
IN WHEN IT BEGAN IT WAS
LANDLINES.
AND SO THAT THERE WAS THAT.
YOU THAT THAT IDEA THAT YOU ONLY
PUT ONE LINE IN.
YOU INCREASED THE CELLPHONES AND
AND.
THAT WAS THE VIEW THAT I TOOK
AND SECOND OF YOU SOME OF THESE
COMMUTERS REPRESENT YOU HAVE.
OF WHAT YOU WOULD CONSIDER ONE
TRADITIONAL FAMILY IN A HOME YOU
HAVE SEVERAL FAMILIES IN A HOME.
AND SO THAT WAS THE VIEW.
IT'S ABOUT TWENTY CLEAR THAT
THAT PIECE UP FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ON THIS QUESTION WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE TO RESPECT THIS PREAMBLE.
WE HAVE A FIRST AND WE OF A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
BUSH'S DEPOSITS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SANTIAGO AYE AYE SANTIAGO AYE
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE NO BONTA.
BONTA AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES I EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I LOW.
LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO MATHIS.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL AYE
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON KNOW QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
EIGHT TO THREE MEASURES OUT
WE'RE CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
WE STILL HAVE AB TWENTY SIX OF
FIFTY TWO CORK A WITHOUT A FIRST
AND A SECOND IT WAS ARE HEARD
DURING ON.
ADDRESS SUBCOMMITTEE WE WE NEED
A FIRST AND SECOND.
WITH A BURST AND WE HAVE A
SECOND.
THANK YOU.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
BUSH'S DEPOSITS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SANTIAGO AYE AYE SANTIAGO AYE
OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE NO BONTA.
BONTA AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I LOW.
LOW AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO MATHIS.
DONALD.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I'VE RODRIGUEZ.
THE THREE MEASURES OUT.
MOVING TO GO BACK TO CARILLO
TWENTY.
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN.
I WHICH IS ON CALL.
MADAM SECRETARY A LIFT COLUSA.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE.
CERVANTES.
SO BONTA AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO.
DONALD.
O'DONNELL DIE.
IT THE FOR MEASURES OUT.
ALMOST DROUGHT MEMBERS CAN ADD
AT THIS POINT A MAN TO CARRY.
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY SIX.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
MATHIS.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL DIE.
BONTA.
BONTA FOR NOT VOTING TURN I.
TEN ZERO MEASURE IS OUT
I'LL LEAVE THE ROLE THE FOR
FIVE MINUTES AND I CAN WAIT A
BIT LONGER IF NECESSARY
WORKS THEM IN THE TIME ANOTHER
FIVE MINUTES
WE SWITCH THE ORDER.
MEN TAKE CARE ITEM NUMBER.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY TWO MATHIS.
THE SNOW.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY SIX MATHIS.
MATHIS I.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB THREE ONE
ONE ONE.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO
.
WORK WORK TURNING THE MEAN FOR
CNC AND YOU IN ANY WILL BEGIN AT
TWO FORTY FIVE